it's about the funnest time I've had in
years um you know what I'm going to I'm
going to R this guys we talk about um so
you'll
understand
um the the type thing comes up and again
we're not we going to get into what it
was going to be or what we wanted to be
I can tell you what it was in a way was
frustrating it was a big giant idea it
was almost like six video games in one
it was the most ambitious thing ever um
and it was kind of fun to try to tackle
it and boy do we tackle it and we
wrestled with it um for for a long time
and it it
sucked um we couldn't figure it
out and it makes you feel just you know
couldn't crack
it imagine the team and this amazing
team it's just frustrated can we do this
and it's like trying to trying to fret a
chord and write the song WR a song why
can't we just make it sound awesome
can't find the harmony
whatever and so when we decided to go
another way like Jeff was saying well we
we've got this why are we doing that
love that why are we doing that and we
decided to do it and suddenly Boom the
music just exploded and we started
looking at you know this game of what it
was and it just Unleashed this tidal
wave of of passion and certainty and
distilled clear ideas and this world
idea and it just it was just this
monstrous thing of of energy so it's
been the funnest year kind of getting
our feet back under us getting our shity
back um I don't know like like that that
magnetic north thing like we found it
again um and it feels good and that was
part of that emotionality on the stage
this morning uh to some degree we needed
it we needed to get it back and we found
it and and and and I hope that people
look at OverWatch as a very clever game
but but I'm tell you under the hood we
needed
this you know um I think just as
developers to kind of just feel that
lightning coursing through it again you
know um so it's that's a really fun part
of OverWatch is that it's kind of in a
weird way I me for for our for our crew
just like this rebirth you know just
simp keep it simple keep it fun okay
thank
you